holy crap everybody they just dropped a
whole bunch of thor ragnarok whole bomb
so I'm gonna explain what's going on
with this preview was all about there's
a new brand of the Marvel giveaway going
on now it's for the action figures all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so this is so great it just looks so
crazy I cannot wait to find out what's
going on with Jeff Goldblum's character
there are a lot of jokes flying around
yesterday about people on set just being
like Jeff Goldblum what is this movie
about and hinges being like what movie
what are you talking about I dressed
like this all the time Jeff Goldblum the
actor has transcended to this place of
weirdness where all the movies he
appears when he is just doing something
completely fascinating so I'm gonna
double down on him as the Grand Master
if you've never read a comic book with
that character he's a really big elder
of the universe who holds the mind gem
that Thanos has to get during Thanos
quest that was the storyline in the
comics where he goes around collecting
all the gems in the Grand Master is sort
of like the final piece in that puzzle
he has to play this crazy chess match
with him so I'll explain his character
but there were a couple big plot teasers
too for the first second and third acts
of the film so we got to talk about all
this but the way they're talking about
the movie itself the way it fits into
the other Thor movies is that because of
the idea of Ragnarok death rebirth is
sort of a reinvention of the franchise
in Kevin Feige is affectionately calling
it the first or movie as if it's like
the first new Thor movie in a new
franchise so no idea what can happen to
Chris Hemsworth in the future but they
do give some teasers because Thor had
short hair for a while in the comics so
it's kind of a rebirth for the
characters as well as the franchise is
going to be crazy and that doesn't even
get into the Hulk stuff Mark Ruffalo
said that Hulk is like a god in this
film he said that he has got so much
swagger he's a completely different
characters and you've seen before so
everybody hoping to see some world
breaker Hulk you will not be
disappointed it is going to be crazy so
let's start with the plot first so this
is just taken directly from the
description that they offer in the film
Thor will arrive in Asgard after hearing
about trouble in his home world
presumably up to that point he's been
traveling around the galaxy trying to
learn more about the visions he had
about Thanos the infinity gems so he
comes back to Asgard
hearing there's trouble and when he
arrives he finds Loki's style of ruling
while he was impersonating Odin has led
to some lapses in the rules and leads to
a freeing of prisoner hella so they
don't say whether or not she's being
kept in their dungeons or whether or not
she's being kept in hell because that's
where she is in the comic so we'll see
how they address that in the movie so
she breaks out wall Thor is there she in
door go at it and she ends up blasting
Thor all the way to Sekar so right off
the bat you have to laugh about the fact
that Loki is a shitty King he got what
he wanted he is king of Asgard even
though he's pretending to be Odin but he
is terrible at it
so now we know how Thor gets to Sekar
but that isn't the end of it so he gets
there and it's a lot like the comic book
version of Sekar the Planet Hulk version
but the big changes they've made is that
the Red King is not in charge the grand
master rules over Sekar and being the
lover of games that he is he's the
person that organizes the Coliseum
matches wherein we find the Hulk
so all these pictures here where you see
them in the bar like look at these crazy
colors it's almost like something out of
a Star Wars movie this is going to be so
great where you see Valkyrie sitting at
the bar Thor finds her he's something of
a fanboy of hers but Valkyrie has been
hiding out she's from Asgard but she's
been hiding out on the car she takes him
to the Grandmaster to become a gladiator
and that's how he gets the hair cut in
the Braveheart makeup and loses his
hammer so they put him into the game
gladiator style are you not entertained
and he has to face their most popular
competitor the Hulk
so then Mark Ruffalo picks up and says
that he is so much more the green mean
machine than the character that you've
seen in previous movies featuring the
Hulk so all the Avengers takes on the
hook that guy is gone where we first
meet him it's almost like the banner
persona has been completely suppressed
and he is completely Hulk so he just
goes crazy it sounds like he's been here
for a while they don't explain exactly
the mechanics of how Hulk wound up on
the car they just say that after
Avengers age of Ultron he winds up there
so we bases Hulk in the arena that's
sort of like the first act of the film
hella breaking out Thor finding out
about the chaos on Asgard in his
absence Odin has been missing so once
they get past the gladiator aspect he's
reunited with the Hulk they move into
the second act of the film that sets off
the road trip element of the film that
they've been talking about Mark Ruffalo
kind of teased that oh it's like a road
trip buddy movie so that sort of tees up
what's going on with the Doctor Strange
elements in the film so earth just seems
like it's going to be one of the stops
during that road trip and in the final
act of the film they were kind of
mysterious about but that's moving into
the Ragnarok portion of the film like
the really big action set piece stuff so
what they said is is it obviously this
is going to be a really funny movie in
the way that Thor is kind of a funny
character I mean it's Thor humor so it's
not going to be like a Judd Apatow movie
or Jim Carrey or something crazy like
that Thor has a very own specific tone
of humor they've been a lot of weird
reactions when people heard that it was
going to be a funny movie don't don't
worry about that it'll still be the
thorah character that you know and love
but they did say in the same breath that
they would have the biggest action set
piece in any Marvel movie to date bigger
than the stuff that we've seen in the
Avengers film which is obviously a hat
tip for the moment of Ragnarok in Odin
unleashing the full power of the
odinforce once he's restored so one of
the big things they left out from all
this talk is the idea that they do find
Odin restore his consciousness in his
memories in him to full power and a scar
because Loki's been impersonating him
this whole time but like you see him
here on Sekar it sounds like him doing
such a crappy job of being king of
Asgard allows Hellas to quickly take
over once she breaks out and kick him
out on the run the same way that she
kicks Thor out
I love the description - she blasts Thor
- Sicard almost makes it sound like she
punches him - sukar even though there's
probably some sort of Asgardian magic
involved but if you remember that huge
behind-the-scenes video does the
director did a while ago I posted it to
my channel so we'll add a link to that
at the end of this because it's actually
pretty long it's almost like 30 minutes
long based on some of the description of
Sekar it leads me to believe that the
place that they're on in that video is
the car because they call it like a very
barbaric planet that's ruled over by the
Grandmaster so thinking of Mad Max
beyond the Thunderdome just reminds me
of this just think Thor beyond the
Thunderdome with Hulk - Avengers enter
one avenger leaves well let me know what
you guys
about all these pictures here I know a
lot of people are like what's going on
with Jeff Goldblum this is what the
Grand Master looks like in the comics
he's way more ridiculous looking in the
comics so I think this is actually
relatively toned down hellas look is
pretty crazy too I'll be interested to
see if they tweaked her backstory a
little bit because they do make it sound
like she's being kept in prison on
Asgard rather than being banished to
Hell by Odin Cate Blanchet did explain a
little bit about her powers and how they
work
she said part of the film will have her
with the helmet on like when you first
see her she will be wearing the hella
helmet from the comics and she can
manifest weapon from her body
she didn't say which parts of her body
like that was a bit of a joke on her
part like I won't tell you which body
parts that I manifest weapons from just
making you wonder but obviously she's
probably talking about her hands and her
shoulders like this full dress here that
will be part of her costume for the
movie and then this picture here
represents what she looks like during a
different part of the movie so there'll
be a couple costume changes for all the
characters like door won't look like
this or the entire movie so neither will
onin Loki anybody else and the really
cool thing that I'm hoping for is a
redesign on Odin's armor cannot wait to
see what that looks like so the other
big thing that you probably notice
immediately in looking at these pictures
is that they crank the color way up it's
almost like they heard that people
thought that Marvel films didn't look
very visually stunning and they're like
oh you want color and they looked at
guardians of the galaxy and they just
cranked the color way up so a lot of
that's in the production design but also
part of the fun of them traveling beyond
the regular nine realms so they said
they would go far beyond the nine realms
in this film that just means that
they'll be traveling all over the galaxy
and the chances of guardians of the
galaxy crossover just rise a hundred
thousand percent just like okay well
they're going to be traveling around
they're probably going to run into some
of the guardians characters so when we
go to Sekar just be looking in the
background shots for Easter eggs for
guardians things because that's really
like the big thing that this movie has
in common with the guardians franchise
is that it's in outer space
it's way far removed from the
earth-based Avengers films and even
though we will go to earth and see
Doctor Strange so we'll touch on some of
that stuff
this is very much a big cosmic movie
because we're talking about the
destruction of Asgard in the galaxy
Ragnarok so hella is going to crush
everyone and she looks so fantastic I
mean Kate Blanchet has been an amazing
actress for forever you watch any of her
movie she's completely amazing so she
was one of the big gets for this like
anthony hopkins is an amazing actor but
i feel like he's been underutilized as
Odin I feel like they corrected that
with Kate Blanchet character so they
will unleash the full fury of hella if
you've ever read her in the comics I'll
do more videos about her as we get
closer to the movie but what will
probably happen is is because guardians
is coming out in May that's probably
when we'll see the first new footage
there might be like a small teaser
before that and obviously a big part of
them selling the movie is going to be
hyping up Thor versus Hulk in the arena
so that might be what some of the first
teasers focused on rather than the
actual story itself but in other related
really crazy news they just announced
the Game of Thrones season 7 premiere
date so that's going to be my other
video today I'll add a link to that at
the end of this but let me know what
other kinds of Marvel bonus videos you
guys want me to do this week there's so
much comic book stuff dropping bunch of
Game of Thrones stuff but a Marvel stuff
bunch of DC stuff so I'll try to get
through it as fast as possible while you
wait for that you can click here for the
brand-new Game of Thrones Season 7
teaser and you can click here to learn
about what's going on with the flash
next week thank you so much for watching
what's that bot I'll see you guys in the
next video